Oh
okay the universe is by definition
everything there there is but of course
we only see a small patch of it we see
only out as far as the speed of light
well well let us and so we think it
began sure I began with a explosive
outbursts called the Big Bang which may
have been the origin of space and time
as well as matter and energy or it might
just have been one bang among an
infinite number scattered throughout
space and time but certainly our region
of the universe had this dramatic hot
explosive origin it's expanding and
cooling and got it's become ever more
enriched and complex over time and so
life and thinking beings like us have
emerged wonder what it all means and as
for its ultimate fate the best evidence
of the moment is it's going to expand
faster and faster and faster and become
totally empty and utterly boring and
it's a rather dismal fate for what is a
rather glorious cosmos